well yeah yes what you get with joe
biden man
let's talk about this story out of uh
out of russia let's talk about the
escalation we have the story um
mcdonald's announces temporary closure
over 800 locations in russia the fast
food giant said it will still pay the
salaries of its employees in both russia
and ukraine i think we might we must
have an error on the timcast.com website
because this says maca o harack that's
not right that's not mcdonald's oh i'm
just i'm kidding it's in cyrillic i love
this
it's funny yeah the the
mac donald's it's an it's like a
weird-looking a
do-ha rack that's what it looks like
it's a cursive r i guess this is just
crazy i mean
facebook leaves russia mcdonald's leaves
russia the big banks leave russia like
they're trying to fix this place yeah i
know so a lot of people are joking that
like russia is going to end up being the
healthiest place on the planet
well i wasn't on chile it was very
disturbing because uh diet coke had been
it surged into the country basically the
last decade prior and obesity was
rampant it was really disturbing i gotta
i got to be completely honest when i
heard that mcdonald's and facebook and
google and apple car and master were all
pulling out i was like i really would
love to be
like to experience
that right now just to like you wake up
and it's quiet it's just quiet you walk
outside and you look around and you
don't hear anything and you're like a
woodpecker in the distance and you're
like and that's it that's the only
information it's just like
so the people in russia i'm sure in all
seriousness are probably i don't think
they're freaking out over mcdonald's to
be honest they're probably worried their
atms aren't working or they're probably
worried i think march 9th tomorrow is
the last day for visa and mastercard to
work so they got to switch over
apparently the local banks are going to
keep facilitating visa and mastercards
internally so visa mastercard can't shut
that down so they're probably going to
be fine yeah that's what i meant when i
was referring to the big banks by the
way is visa mastercard pulling out this
deloitte there's like ernst young
there's a bunch of big financial uh
international financial organizations
that are cutting off russia there's a
lot like it's it's not even that too
like fifa banned russia's soccer team
from the world cup yeah the ca video
games yeah yeah they said cats they bad
russian cats from competing
the kids of course the canadians get it
they those cats deserve everything
they're getting that's right this the
chl which is the canadian junior hockey
league which is like one of the biggest
you know junior hockey leagues in the
world you know a lot of they banned
russians from being drafted into the chl
um and you know i did my part when i was
at the bar the other night somebody
ordered a moscow mule and i immediately
just punched him in the face
perfect not a true story
right that's gonna be the new phrase
what well i was gonna say the real blow
to russia
all of these like international
institutions are leaving russia it's
it's like imagine there's a giant
like squid alien creature with its
tentacles all over all these countries
and something happened to where they're
like repeat they're like pulling away
from russia and it's finally clearing a
path the vines are being torn away and
now russia is just like
i mean these these look
if you are one of these people who
thinks late stage capitalism is awful
you should probably be happy these
companies are like
pulling out of russia because i got to
be honest i understand making life
harder for russians and affecting their
economy is a bad thing
but google facebook mcdonald's going
away would not be that concerned because
if there really was a revolution in the
united states like a good healthy
revolution that the
corporate govern like the global
corporations would just cut us all off
we would lose mcdonald's from mcdonald's
and our money our bank accounts
our gas would go up to 90 a gallon or
whatever that's true no you're right i
think there's something there just buy
an electric car yeah it's just buy
electricity yeah just buy them just
because you got 60 grand no problem
don't worry about guests right you get
an electric car energy you get an
electric it's also just like a giant
virtue signal too because these same
corporations will never stop doing
business in china because they have so
much more financial interest in china
like all like they're all read that word
what about a taiwan what does that word
say
i can't temporarily temporarily yeah
temporarily yeah temporarily yeah yeah
what does that mean until they until
they want to stop basically it means
they're not really doing anything yeah
they're uh temporary it's especially
funny with fifa too because the world
cup this year is literally being held in
qatar
not exactly a friendly country to human
rights aren't there like uh human bones
in the structure literally world cup
stage they're using slave labor to build
the stadium and when and i've heard this
could be wrong i could be wrong about
this so definitely factor me about fact
check i heard when the slaves die they
just push them into the construction of
the building and just build over them
well i don't know if that's i don't i
don't know i can't i can't confirm or
deny but i know from my uh history class
that that's what they did to build the
pyramids yeah and the great wall of
china it's historically impressive i
don't know if that's true though i was
reading about the pyramids or yeah i
think great wall china is what i meant
to say great walmart i mean it's massive
did you worry about that well for sure
seeing forced labor at world cup stadium
from the bbc in qatar this is from 2022.
yeah i heard they just like put the
bodies into the construction of the
building like they just
when they're sealing off an area
cementing it they just dump the body and
then pour the cement over it and feel
like me are you serious i've heard that
i thought hyperbolic yeah no no no legit
like wow i've heard some some of those
stories but it could just be propaganda
qatar migrant workers unpaid for months
of work on fifa stadium this is from
amnesty.org
so people are going and they're not
getting paid migrants are coming in and
getting basically forced slave labor
yeah so hats off to fifa for banning
russia from their video game while
they're about to host the world cup yeah
i hope you guys make some money from the
world cup
that's why you're doing it right yeah
right so uh guardian says six thousand
five hundred migrant workers have died
in qatar since the world cup awarded is
it cutter or qatar either okay yeah it
depends on who you ask oh yeah yeah it's
like how you can spell healthcare with
either a space or all one word right
well it's funny to me that mcdonald's is
coming out of russia and they refuse to
do anything about china where they are
actually actively racist in their
commercials mcdonald's themselves is
like company they basically endorse it
they just go along with it because it's
what china wants anything china wants
china i guess is a much bigger deal in
russia and yeah and like going off that
like
obviously we're mad by how expensive gas
has gotten due to the fact that the
world is sanctioning of one of the
biggest oil producers in the world
imagine if china invades taiwan and all
of a sudden all these same countries are
now sanctioning
china which produces like 80 of the
ingredients in our medicines and a lot
of our semiconductors like i know we
complain about the price of gas but
imagine we're sanctioning a country that
produces so much of our manufactured
goods on the upside maybe china won't
invade taiwan because they will be
sanctioned like this and they'll have
total cut off from the global economy
so i don't know about that that story
about bodies being in the stadium
because that might have been propaganda
to manipulate but i did see a report
that said 34 deaths in the construction
of the stadium and now i'm looking at
this story about fifa and inundated with
17 million requests for world cup
tickets so it's just kind of like
you know
this is a country that we've heavily
criticized that uh exploits people to an
extreme degree and we're like yeah but
they're cool
russia it brings a new definition to
built on the backs of slaves
literally slavery
there's more slaves alive today than
there's ever been right incredible dude
i was just coming to terms with just
accepting the slavery on earth right now
like
this plastic was i mean these materials
these apple materials are built by like
slave labor in china i don't know the
specifics but like
okay
use it like fuel to fix the system but
it's horrifying
it's the way things are man that's
screwed up this is the reality think
about it
we really don't think about this shop
labor that often
it's not it's not even necessarily
that's americans
and it's mostly as democrat types don't
want to talk about it they're they're
the ones who get uh who get angry and
make the comics dismissing any criticism
of them
protesting issues that they actually
support right so when you have people
saying at occupy wall street like oh
these billionaire elites and then they
put up a shrine to steve jobs i'm like
let's see a little hypocrisy there like
this is the guy who's exploiting labor i
i despise apple products designed in
cupertino i absolutely love apple it's
like they you know i remember i had a
friend who was in college and
she was like my school is making me buy
an apple desktop for for design and i
was like
why
and she's like you have to otherwise
they fail you and then i was like
except
you can get the same powered computer
running the mac os for a third of the
cost if you build it yourself and she's
like they won't allow that yeah no it's
crazy i absolutely despise this company
man no i and as somebody who works in
your creative field who does animation
who spent a decent amount of time around
other animators there's absolutely no
reason that you need to use a mac to
just work that's right but apple played
it really really smart by making it
these these these college kids would get
student loans and they'd spend a
thousand bucks on a 300 computer mm-hmm
and it's like what what what is the mac
os like a rebranded unix system
i don't know probably yeah i think it is
and so then all of a sudden you get
occupy wall street they're like next
good and then we're gonna we're gonna
celebrate put up a shrine for steve jobs
trendy looks cool you know what man i
will say this the virus thing ma'am they
don't get viruses
mac os
right that's a lie they don't everyone i
know every everyone i know who has a mac
has said they don't get viruses on it
and i absolutely in the early days of
the excellent marketing from apple
uh
there was the narrative saying that
apples don't get viruses and it just
works and that's technically true what
was happening was
apples were less likely to get viruses
because their market share was like oh
yes
and the same thing is true for linux
people say like oh well ubuntu doesn't
get viruses either and it's like yeah
because like point zero three percent of
people are using a bunch granted you
know a lot of stores like walmart i
don't know i don't know specifically
walmart but a lot of big box stores use
linux for all of their point-of-sale
terminals and self-checkouts because
it's free
they don't want to pay but i think i
think walmart might use xp or something
dude all for all my talk about not
trusting the media i bought their
narrative about apple not getting
viruses shame on me
but one thing i was i was pointing out
earlier was uh i love that they write
designed in cupertino on their products
it's like you mean made in china like i
don't care if it's designed here yeah
you made it somewhere else
i didn't think that like nobody thought
that you were having the people working
in the sweatshops design the products
you're not progressive for doing that
here designed in my luxury apartment
yeah
california thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you